you know a lady in Texas recognizes the
power of images as well recognizes that
there is more to this whole pandemic
than just you know sort of get getting
your material goods satisfying your own
immediate desires this woman is a salon
owner she opened her salon for a week in
defiance of the lockdown and she was
arrested for it in a judge sentenced her
to a week in jail and a seven thousand
dollar fine for opening her salon
business and just you know trying to
trying to feed her kids so the judge
Eric Moy told this owner Shelly Luthor
owner of salon alamode that he would not
make her go to jail if she just admitted
that what she did was selfish and wrong
here's this woman's answer judge I would
like to say that I have much respect for
this court and laws and that I've never
been been in this position before and
it's not someplace that I want to be but
I have to disagree with you sir when I
when you say that I'm selfish because
feeding my kids is not selfish I have
hairstylists that are going hungry
because they'd rather feed their kids so
sir if you think the law is more
important than kids getting fed then
please go ahead with your decision but I
am NOT gonna shut the salon damn right
oh this woman deserves a prize I want I
want President Trump to give her some
kind of metal I don't know medal of
freedom medals I love this it's such
it's such an obscure moment right she's
in some tiny courtroom in Texas nobody's
watching no cameras I mean I guess there
are cameras now because we're in this
lockdown I guess that's how we got this
footage but she's not on a big stage
she's not on a TV show and yet the
question came down to one of integrity
and that's where questions of integrity
really come when you think nobody's
watching
the judge said this is like out of
George Orwell instead of 1984 yes I'll
go easy on your sentence if you just
admit that feeding your children was
selfish and wrong and you'll always do
exactly what the government tells you to
do even if it's based on bunk science
even if it's an arbitrary power grab you
do what we say say uncle
he's basically twisting your arm behind
your back say uncle say uncle
and she said nah I think I'd rather go
to jail because you can take my week
away from me you can take my money away
from me you can take me away from my
kids but you can't take my integrity you
can make me scream but you can't make me
sing I love it I I'm so inspired by this
woman we should we should get this video
going all around the judge should be
ashamed of himself
[Music]
[Music]